>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Catalina Gómez: We are
delighted to start this new series.
We're starting a series called Poet
2 Poet, Poeta a Poeta, and we --
our idea is to have a poet, a poet
who's alive, to honor one of the --
a great poet of the
Hispanic language.
We are starting this great
series here today with Consuelo,
who's going to be doing a
homage to César Vallejo.
I want to take an opportunity
to also tell you
about the Hispanic Reading Room
of the Library of Congress.
The Hispanic Reading Room
is a primary access point
for research related to the
Caribbean, Latin America, Spain,
and Portugal and is
open to everyone.
Whoever has a reader's card
can use our Reading Room
so everyone is welcome.
If anyone wants to find out
more about our programs,
please visit our website, which
is www.loc.gov/rr/hispanic.
And now to today's event.
We're going to have Consuelo, who's
going to do a homage to, as I said,
Peruvian poet César Vallejo,
one of our most beloved
poets of Latin America.
And then Consuelo's going to
read from Vallejo together
with Maureen Contreni, who is
going to read the poems in English,
and then Consuelo is
going to move --
she's going to then read some of
her work and Contreni is going
to read the English translations.
About our feature speakers, Consuelo
Hernández was born in Colombia
and has lived in Venezuela, Peru,
Puerto Rico, and the United States.
She has published four
collections of poems,
among them Voces de la
soledad, Solo de violín,
poemario para músicos y
pintores, Manual de peregrina,
and the bilingual collection
Poemas de escombros y cenizas,
and in English that one is titled
Poems from Debris and Ashes,
and the book that we're here to --
to celebrate, and the one
that she'll be reading
from today, Mi reino sin orillas.
Consuelo's poetry has been
included in numerous anthologies.
She has received many, many
honors, including distinction
from the international poetry
contest of Ciudad Melilla in Spain
and the Letras de Oro contest
at the University of Miami.
She is also -- in 2011, she received
the Antonio Machado Poetry Award
in Madrid, Spain, and
the Mid-Atlantic Council
of Latin American Studies,
among many other honors.
And Consuelo is also Associate
Professor at the World Languages
and Cultures Department at American
University here in Washington.
As I said, she will be
accompanied by Maureen Contreni,
who has translated some of
Consuelo's poetry, and Maureen --
Maureen graduated also
from American University.
That's where she met Consuelo.
And she's an attorney, and she has
traveled extensively throughout
Latin America, so I'm assuming
that's why you love translating
Latin American poetry.
One last announcement.
We will be selling -- Consuelo
is selling her book at the book
and maybe she'll be glad to
sign some copies at the end.
So the books are located
there in the back.
With no further adieu, please join
me in welcoming Consuelo Hernández.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Consuelo Hernández: Thank you,
Catalina, for that presentation.
Good afternoon and thank you for
making the trip up here today
in this beautiful raining day.
It feels so good to see
many familiar faces,
friends, and colleagues.
Thank you.
I want to give my special thanks to
Catalina Gómez and Dr. [inaudible],
who from the Hispanic
Division of the Library
of Congress invited me
for this special event.
I am also very grateful with Maureen
Contreni, my dear translator.
She -- she has translated
for my books.
This is the first time we
are sharing one reading.
She is a busy attorney, a
wonderful mother of two,
and a very exceptional friend.
I met Maureen at American University
I think around 20 years ago
and when she was in
my freshmen class.
It was one star already completely
[inaudible] in Portuguese, Spanish,
and English, and I don't know if she
has learned another language, but --
and I was astonished
by her translation.
So until now, though she doesn't
dedicate only to translate,
she translated my book, and thank
you for that and for being here.
I also would like to dedicate this,
this poetry reading, to my Peruvian
and Colombian brothers and
sisters that are facing the most,
the worst catastrophe,
natural catastrophe,
that they have suffered
in the last decades.
And Trujillo, the city
where Vallejo spent most
of his more important
intellectual and formational years,
is one of the cities more affected.
So we have that day in mind today.
It is a great pleasure for
me and a big honor to be
in this city celebrating the
greatest, the most wonderful,
and the most beloved poet or Latin
American during the 20th century.
César Vallejo is the poet --
is the poet really from
the avant-garde times.
He was a poet that before Breton
published the Surrealist Manifesto
he was already surrealist
[inaudible] he lives only 46 years,
from 1892 to 1918, but
those years were enough
to write an immortal --
immortal book of poetry.
At the beginning of the year, I was
contacted by Catalina and asked me
to give the name of one poet that
has been influencing my world
or somebody that I really like
and honestly I couldn't
give her only one name.
There are many poets that I
have read and many that I enjoy,
so I sent a list of
six names and let her
to choose whoever she consider more
appropriate to start the series.
And some days later, I
received a letter, an email,
telling me that the selected
poem was César Vallejo
and I was just thrilled and in some
way I thought what a coincidence
because Vallejo is one of those
very few poets that when I read
for the first time
he moved me to tears.
And I think that everybody
who reads Vallejo can cry
when you read those poems.
So I -- I start to think what
do I have in common with Vallejo
and I really don't know how
much of Vallejo's in my poetry.
I'm going to leave this
word for the critics,
but I try to find some comparalisms
[phonetic] between his life
and my life and the motivation
he has to write poetry
and my own motivations and I --
I'm going just to mention some
because I think it is useful
to illustrate who was this Vallejo.
One thing in common is
that we're born on March 16
and March 16 is his
date when he's born
and March 16 is my
official birthday.
Another thing is our
provincial origins.
He was born in Santiago de
Chuco in Peru highlands,
in a provincial town, in an
environment very religious.
His parents were both mestizo
and they were son and daughter
from priests in Peru so they
have that religious formation
since the very beginning.
So I thought that that was
interesting because I'm also
from a little town in Colombia,
from the Andean mountains,
one hour from Medellín, El Peñón,
and I lived there for 10 years.
Vallejo moved from Santiago de Chuco
to Trujillo and to Lima in order
to study and I moved
when I was 10 to --
with my family to Medellín
also to get education
and go to the university.
By the way, here is
one of my professors
from the University of Antioquia.
I was really surprised because he
was my professor I think 50 years
ago, around that, and she's also a
translator, Patricia [Inaudible].
And then Vallejo, after those years
in Trujillo and in Lima started
in an agrarian intellectual
development, he decided to go
to France, and from France
he travelled to the Institute
of [Inaudible], especially
to Russia.
He went four times because
of his political convictions.
And then he went also
to Spain to collaborate
with the republican courts.
In my case, I moved to
Venezuela more by spiritual
and idealistic convictions,
too, and [inaudible] political
and then I went to Peru, to
Puerto Rico, and finally I came
to the United States
where I did my Ph.D.
and I definitely stayed
here already 30 years.
So, but the -- our similarities
in our lives doesn't end here.
We -- I think what delineates his
poetry is also common to my poetry.
He has -- he's chosen his
poetry on profound necessity
and absolutely freedom and at the
same the possibility to find it.
His nostalgia also for his lost
paradise of the [inaudible],
the memories of his family,
especially his mother
and his brother, his
suffering for the loss --
losses that he had during his life.
He lost his brother in 1915, his
mother in 1918, then his father.
He was also in jail for 112 days.
So he has a very difficult life
and that shows in his poetry, too.
And he has an existential
anguish and a kind of sense
of feeling an orphan in this
world, lonely, in solitude,
and besides that he had the
conscience for political
and social justice, and
that put him into trouble
because of his political
convictions.
He was expelled from France
and he had to live in Spain
for certain times and
he went back to Spain.
But anyway, in his poetry there are
also the eternal themes of poetry,
death, love, life, and
in a way this is --
this is also present in my poetry,
so I think that the selection
of César Vallejo was a very
just for our reading today.
But we are not here to hear
another scholarly presentation.
This is something that you can read
in many critic studies
about his poetry.
There are also many biographies
and some of them exceptional,
like the one written by
Juan Espejo Asturrizaga.
So we are going to go into
his poetry and I am going
to try and put into context.
Any time I read a poem, I am
going to put it into context
and Maureen is going to
read the translation.
He wrote several books of poetry,
but when he died he
only had published two
and both self-published.
I want to emphasize that
they were self-published
because many times we devaluate
self-publications and one gigantic
like this published Los
heraldos negros [inaudible]
that doesn't have any translation
because it's a word, a neologismo,
it's a word invented
by him [inaudible].
He published by himself
with his own money
in Lima before going to France.
And since he went to Europe he
didn't publish any other poetic book
and all the rest of his work
was unpublished until he died.
His widow was the one that
published the other books.
So this is his complete
work on poetry and half
of this was unpublished
when he died.
So we're going to start the reading
with one poem entitled
Los heraldos negros.
Esta poema de Los heraldos negro
abre este libro y habla de el choque
tremendo que tuvo César Vallejo
cuando recibió un telegrama de su
hermano que decía sobre
la muerte de su madre.
Entonces --
Es un poema muy fuerte y muy bello.
Los heraldos negros.
Hay golpes en la vida, tan fuertes.
Yo no sé.
Golpes como del odio de
Dios, como si -- si --
Lo siento.
Necesito [inaudible].
[ Background speaking ]
Volvamos a empezar.
Los heraldos negros.
Hay golpes en la vida, tan fuertes.
Yo no sé.
Golpes como del odio de
Dios, como si ante ellos,
la resaca de todo lo sufrido
se empozara en el alma.
Yo no sé.
Son pocos, pero son.
Abren zanjas oscuras en el rostro
más fiero y en el lomo más fuerte.
Serán tal vez los potros
de bárbaros attilas,
o los heraldos negros
que nos manda la Muerte.
Son las caídas hondas
de los cristos del alma,
de alguna fe adorable
que el Destino blasfema.
Esos golpes sangrientos son las
crepitaciones de algún pan que en
la puerta del horno se nos quema.
Y el hombre.
Pobre. Pobre.
Vuelve los ojos, como cuando por
sobre el hombro nos llama una
palmada, vuelve los ojos locos,
y todo lo vivido se empoza,
como un charco de culpa,
en la mirada.
Hay golpes en la vida, tan fuertes.
Yo no sé.
>> Maureen Contreni: Thank you
very much for having me here.
The black heralds.
There are blows in
life, so powerful.
I don't know.
Blows like God's hatred
as if before them.
the undertow of everything
suffered or to well up in the soul.
I don't know.
They're few, but they exist.
They open dark furrows in
the most ferocious face
and the most powerful loins.
Perhaps they're wooden
horses of barbaric attilas
or black messengers
that Death sent to us.
They're profound lapses
of the soul's christs,
of some adorable faith
that Destiny blasphemes.
Those bloodthirsty blows
are crackling of some bread
that in the oven's
door burns up on us.
And man. Poor, poor man.
He turns his eyes as when a slap
on the shoulder calls us by name.
He turns his crazed eye and
everything he's lived wells
up like a pool of guilt in his gaze.
There are blows in
life, so powerful.
I don't know.
>> Consuelo Hernández: Yeah.
Los pasos lejanos.
In this poem, Vallejo is already
far from Santiago de Chuco
and he's missing his family.
So the central figures here are
his father and his peaceful mother.
Mi madre duerme -- perdón.
Mi padre duerme.
Su semblante augusto
figura un apacible corazón,
está ahora tan dulce.
Si hay algo en él
de amargo, seré yo.
Hay soledad en el hogar, se reza,
y no hay noticias de los hijos hoy.
Mi padre se despierta,
ausculta la huida a Egipto,
el restañate adiós.
Está ahora tan cerca, si hay
algo en él de lejos, seré yo.
Y mi madre pasea allá
en los huertos,
saboreando un sabor ya sin sabor.
Está ahora tan suave, tan
ala, tan salida, tan amor.
Hay soledad en el hogar sin bulla,
sin noticias, sin verde, sin niñez.
Y si hay algo quebrado en esta
tarde, y que baja y que cruje,
son dos viejos caminos
blancos, curvos.
Por ellos va mi corazón a pie.
>> Maureen Contreni:
Distant footsteps.
My father sleeps.
His august expression
suggests a tranquil heart.
Now he's so sweet.
If there's anything bitter
in him, it must be me.
There's loneliness at home.
He prays. And there's no
news of the children today.
My father wakes up, listening inside
himself for the flight into Egypt,
the goodbye that stops
the flow of blood.
Now he's so close.
If there's anything distant
in him, it must be me.
Out there, my mother
passes through the orchards,
already savoring the
savor without savor.
Now she's so soft, so much
wing, so gone, so much love.
There's loneliness at
home with no noisy brood,
no news, no green, no childhood.
And this afternoon, if there's
anything broken that stoops over
and creaks, it's two
old white, curvy roads.
Down them my heart travels on foot.
>> Consuelo Hernández:
A mi hermano Miguel.
Miguel was the closest
brother to César.
César is the 11th of the 11
children of this big family
and Miguel -- Miguel was
the one before the last one,
so they were very close.
And he died in 1915.
So this poem is A mi
hermano Miguel, In memoriam.
Hermano, hoy estoy en
el poyo de la casa.
Donde nos haces una falta sin fondo.
Me acuerdo que jugábamos esta hora,
y que mama nos acariciaba:
Pero, hijos.
Ahora yo me escondo, como antes,
todas estas oraciones vespertinas,
y espero que tú no des conmigo.
Por la sala, el zaguán,
los corredores.
Después, te ocultas
tú, y yo no doy contigo.
Me acuerdo que nos hacíamos
llorar, hermano, en aquel juego.
Miguel, tú te escondiste una
noche de agosto, al alborear, pero,
en vez de ocultarte
riendo, estabas triste.
Y tu gemelo corazón de esas
tardes extintas se ha aburrido de
no encontrarte.
Y ya cae sombra en el alma.
Oye, hermano, no tardes en salir.
¿Bueno? Puede inquietarse mamá.
>> Maureen Contreni:
To my brother Miguel.
Brother, I am sitting on
the bench at our house,
where your absence
is a bottomless pit.
I remember that this is
the time we used to play
and that Mama would
pat us and say, "Boys!
Boys!" Now I'm hiding as I used to
from all those even-tied prayers
and hoping you don't
stumble upon me.
Through the sala, the
entry hall, the corridors.
Later you go hide and
I don't find you.
I remember that we made each other
cry, brother, playing that game.
Miguel, you hid one night in August
near dawn, but instead of laughing
as you hid, you were
sad and your twin heart
from those bygone afternoons
is weary from not finding you.
and now a shadow is
falling over my soul.
Listen, brother, don't
wait too long to come out.
Alright? You might upset Mama.
>> Consuelo Hernández: Ahora vamos
a leer dos poemas from Trilce.
Trilce es el [inaudible], el
libro mas importante de la
vanguardia latinoamericana.
Vallejo, sin escuelas, sin --
sin manifiestos, sin seguidores,
aquejado como la figura mas
epígono de la vanguardia.
A diferencia de otros poetas que
sí tuvieron escuela o sí tuvieron
manifiestos y formaron seguidores.
Como dije antes Trilce
es una palabra inventada.
Algunos malinterpretado que es la
combinación de triste y dulce pero
en realidad el en una entrevista
dijo que no significada nada,
que estaba buscando un titulo
bueno para poner a su --
a su libro y que [inaudible] jugando
con [inaudible] trilce y decidió
que es el titulo mas
apropiado para su libro.
El libro tiene 77 poemas y
ninguno tiene titulo que nos
puedan orientar.
Es sobre contenido.
Asi que vamos a leer el poema No.
18. Este poema se refiere a sus
dias en la cárcel y añoranza que
[inaudible] ante de la madre como
la posible solución al abandono que
esta sufriendo.
I said all of this in Spanish.
I'm going to make a summary.
Trilce is one of the most
important books of poetry in --
for the avant-garde, the
movement, in Latin America.
And this poem that I am going
to read now talks about
his time in jail.
He was arrested thoroughly
and totally unjusted --
unjustified, and he wrote
this poem when he was in jail.
And the day he was liberated,
he read this poem to his friends
and Juan Espejo says that when
he was reading this poem he was
in tears.
Oh, las cuatro paredes de la celda.
Ah, las cuatro paredes
albicantes que sin remedio dan al
mismo número.
Criadero de nervios mala brecha,
por sus cuatro rincones
cómo arranca las diarias
aherrojadas extremidades.
Amorosa llavera de innumerables
llaves, si estuvieras aquí,
si vieras hasta qué hora
son las cuatro estas paredes.
Contra ellas seríamos contigo,
los dos, más dos que nunca.
Y ni lloraras, di, ¡Libertadora!
Ah, las cuatro paredes de la celda.
De ellas me duelen entretanto,
más las dos largas que tienen esta
noche algo de madres que ya muertas
llevan por bromurados declives,
a un niño de la mano cada una.
Y sólo yo me voy quedando, con la
diestra, que hace por ambas manos,
en alto, en busca de terciario
brazo que ha de pupilar,
entre mi dónde y cuándo, esta
mayoría inválida de hombre.
>> Maureen Contreni:
This is Poem No.
18. Oh, the four walls of the cell.
Ah, the four whitening walls that
helplessly face the same number.
Place where the nerves
are born the worst way,
through its four corners
how it drags
around the shackled daily limbs.
Tender keeper of innumerable
keys, if you were here,
if you could see just how late
these walls are still four.
Against them we'd be with you,
the two of us, more two than ever,
and you wouldn't even cry.
Speak up, liberator.
Ah, the walls, the cell.
Meanwhile, I hurt most from the
two long ones that tonight look
like mothers already dead,
who each lead a child by hand
down shear cliffs of bromine.
And here I'm still alone with my
right hand, which does for both held
up high, in search of tertiary arm
which has to tutor between my where
and my when this invalid
majority of man.
>> Consuelo Hernández:
Now we'll read the Poem No.
28. This is an absolute beauty.
When I read this poem
for the first time,
this is one of the
poems that made me cry.
I was far from my home, too.
I was in Venezuela.
And it's -- it captures
in an exceptional way,
with so much intensity,
the nostalgia for his home
and also with every day worse.
I will read it.
He almorzado solo ahora, y no
he tenido madre, ni súplica,
ni sírvete, ni agua, ni padre que,
en el facundo ofertorio
de los choclos,
pregunte para su tardanza de imagen,
por los broches mayores del sonido.
Cómo iba yo a almorzar.
Cómo me iba a servir de tales
platos distantes esas cosas,
cuando habráse quebrado
el propio hogar,
cuando no asoma ni
madre a los labios.
Cómo iba yo a almorzar nonada.
A la mesa de un buen amigo he
almorzado con su padre recién
llegado del mundo, con sus canas
tías que hablan en tordillo retinte
de porcelana, bisbiseando por
todos sus viudos alvéolos,
y con cubiertos francos
de alegres tiroriros,
porque estánse en su casa.
Así, ¡qué gracia!
Y me han dolido los cuchillos
de esta mesa en todo el paladar.
El yantar de estas mesas así,
en que se prueba amor ajeno
en vez del propio amor,
torna tierra el brocado
que no brinda la madre,
que hace golpe la dura
deglución, el dulce, hiel,
aceite funéreo, el café.
Cuando ya se ha quebrado
el propio hogar,
y el sírvete materno
no sale de la tumba,
la cocina a oscuras,
la miseria de amor.
>> Maureen Contreni: Now
I have eaten lunch alone
and have had no mother or entreaty
or help yourself, or water,
or father, who in his fluent
offertory of boiled corn,
asks about his delay of image and
for the larger clasps of sound.
How was I going to eat, how was I
going to serve myself those things
from such distant plates, when our
very hearth will have been broken,
when not even a glimpse
of mother touches my lips.
How was I going to eat a bite.
I have had lunch at the
table of a good friend,
with his father recently
arrived from the world,
with his white-haired aunts
chattering in the dappled chinking
of china, buzzing about
all the ovulate widowers
and generous place settings
of joyous tootlings,
because they are in the house.
Ah, how pleasant, and the knives
of this table have hurt
every bit of my pallet.
Thus the victuals of these tables,
which demonstrate altruistic rather
than selfish love, turn to dirt the
mouthful not offered by the mother,
make difficult deglutition a
blow, the sweet bile, coffee,
funereal oil, when your own
heart has already been broken
and the maternal help yourself does
not leave the tomb, the kitchen,
in darkness, the misery of love.
>> Consuelo Hernández: From
Poemas Humanos, that was the book
that was published posthumously,
we will read Piedra blanca --
Piedra negra sobre una piedra
blanca, and it's a premonition
of his own death, though
he didn't die on Thursday
and in a fall as the poem says.
He died on a rainy
Holy Friday in spring,
15 April, the month of poetry.
Piedra negra sobre
una piedra blanca.
Me moriré en París con aguacero,
un día del cual tengo
ya el recuerdo.
Me moriré en París y no me corro,
tal vez un jueves,
como es hoy de otoño.
Jueves será, porque hoy,
jueves, que proso estos versos,
los húmeros me he puesto a la mala
y, jamás como hoy, me he vuelto,
con todo mi camino, a verme solo.
César Vallejo ha muerto, le pegaban
todos sin que él les haga nada,
le daban duro con un palo y
duro también con una soga,
son testigos los días jueves y
los jueves -- los huesos húmeros,
la soledad, la lluvia, los caminos.
>> Maureen Contreni: Black
stone on a white stone.
I will die in Paris with hard
dirty rain on a day I now remember.
I will die in Paris,
and I don't run.
Maybe a Thursday, like
today, in autumn.
Thursday, because today,
Thursday, when I prose these lines,
I have forced my humeri
on unwillingly and never
like today have I again, with
all my road, seen myself alone.
César Vallejo is dead.
They beat him everyone, without
him doing anything to them.
They hit him hard with a stick
and hard likewise with a rope.
Witnesses are the Thursdays
and humerus bones the
loneliness, the rain, the roads.
>> Consuelo Hernández: Now
it's going to be very difficult
to read my own work in front of
this amazing beauty, but I was going
to read some of my
poems from my new book.
Before, I want to thank all the
people that made possible this book
because the cover was made by
Phyllis Portella [assumed spelling],
one painter that lives in New York.
The back cover is a comment
by Iris Guzman, the translator
of so many Latin American
writers and Hispanic writers.
The pictures were taken by
Daniel Adino [assumed spelling].
I also want to thank my husband
for his support always and for --
because he was instrumental
in deciding what title
to give to the book, too.
And of course to Maureen,
that translated the book.
So I'm going to read
like five minutes, eight,
so we have time to
discuss the reading.
Recomienzo.
Reinicio este constante desplazarme
atravieso montañas desiertos y
llanuras ni míos ni tuyos los
dominios de la imaginación.
Ríos, volcanes, lavas y cenizas
un incendio interior me devora.
Las sombras cabargan en la nueva
aurora peregrino por las cuatro
estaciones derrumbo murallas
confundida entre la turba entre el
huracán y las aves.
Busco la antorcha.
La palabra que dé en el blanco
el aroma de la hierba silvestre la
patria de nostalgias y viborea en
mi cuerpo una violenta sensación
de amor.
>> Maureen Contreni: Again.
It begins again, this
relentless journey over deserts
and plains neither mine nor yours
but dominions of imagination.
By lamplight I grope my way across
rivers, volcanoes, lava, and ash.
A fire devours me from within.
I return from the night
on the wings of sunrise,
a pilgrim crossing the four seasons.
I demolish the ancient
walls of cities,
confused in the teeming crowds
between the hurricane and the birds
in search of a sliver of
light from a single word.
Let the smell of wild grass,
the mother of nostalgia,
strike at the heart of the
target and twist inside me
with the violence of love.
>> Consuelo Hernández: I have
to say that this book was written
after I had experience of
suffer cancer and in front
of one experience so hard, an
obstacle that's big to overcome,
I come to value as never
life and also to find support
in the highest inner self
or in whatever you believe
that can help you in those moments.
And I wrote this poem
too in those times.
Tu nombre.
Digo tu nombre y todos se ilumina.
Pienso en tu nombre y
estoy lista para el viaje.
Sueno tu nombre y me
despierto de una pesadilla.
Escribo tu nombre y
aparece la palabra amor.
Te llamo y brota agua en
el desierto de mi pena.
Grito tu nombre y fecundas
de fulgor el universo.
Me lleno de tu nombre y hay
esperanza limpia en mis caminos.
Me abrazas, me besas y estoy viva.
>> Maureen Contreni: Your name.
I say your name and
everything lights up.
I think about your name and
I am ready for a voyage.
I dream your name and I
awake from a nightmare.
I write your name and
the word love appears.
I call to you and water sprouts
from the desert of my sorrow.
I shout your name and you impregnate
the universe with radiance.
I fill myself with your name and
there is clean hope in my pathway.
You hold me, you kiss
me, and I am alive.
>> Consuelo Hernández: This
other poem is also something
that I felt a necessity to
write when I was sick and it's
to encourage people
to live even though
if they are very depressed
or with a hard pain.
I have had in my life friends
that have commit suicide,
students that come to my
office with this immense pain,
and at those moments
you realize that --
the moments when you are really sick
and you realize how
much is important life
and how much you value
life as the biggest present
that we have in this world.
So I wrote this poem to -- to
encourage people to value life
and to forget those
ideas to commit suicide.
Poema para suicidas.
Atrapa la llama que alumbra tus
orillas y posterga el descenso hacia
el abismo aunque sientas que no hay
dolor más grande que el dolor de
estar vivo ni mayor pesadumbre
que la vida consciente.
Un veneno no sacia la
sed de firmamentos.
No prives de la brisa a tus pulmones
archiva navajas y cuchillos no
visualices tu sangre a borbotones.
Enciende las luminarias de tu alma.
Olvida las balas que marcaron
golondrinas con muertes imaginares y
con el placer que bailas cumbia
o vallenato manda a la muerte a
pudrirse en las letrinas.
Antes de que emprendas tu regreso,
descubre del cóndor su saber y
serena sin vértigo, sin asco,
ante la carroña de los precipicios,
aprende a navegar en las alturas.
>> Maureen Contreni:
For the suicidal.
Trap the flame that illuminates your
shores and hold back the dissent
into the abyss even though you
feel there is no pain greater
than the pain of being alive nor
grief heavier than conscious life.
Poison does not quench
thirst for the heavens.
Do not deprive your
lungs of the breeze.
File away the razors and knives.
Do not visualize your blood gushing.
Light the lamps of your soul.
Forget the bullets that branded
the swallows with imaginary deaths.
And with the pleasure with which
you danced the cumbia or vallenato,
send Death to rot in the latrine.
Before you set out on your
return, find the condor's wisdom
and serenely, without vertigo or
disgust, faced with the carrion
of the precipices, learn to
navigate in the highlands.
>> Consuelo Hernández:
Casa de la infancia.
Hoy volvé a rodar la lluvia entre
las tejas y salgo del cementerio
mi abuelita.
Se sentó como siempre
en alumbra de la cocina,
con la mirada fijen
y ciertos a resuntas,
y yo a tristezas por el cristo
fue que cantaba entre las ramas.
Mi corazón se durmió
bajo las dalias.
Mi ser senté rojo en todo
ese tiempo con las sales
aurora luminosa.
Siempre tengo que volverá la casa
de la infancia [inaudible] fugar en
ese país [inaudible] por esos
caminos que no tienen piedad de
las viajeras.
>> Maureen Contreni: Childhood home.
Today the rain slipped
between the tiles
and my grandmother hopped
out of the cemetery.
She sat as usual on the
threshold of the kitchen
with her gaze set on
uncertain horizons.
And it rained sorrows for the great
cicadae sitting among the branches.
My heart fell asleep
beneath the dahlias.
My being was interred along
with that time, with the birds
from some other luminous aurora.
I always have to return
to my childhood home,
to flounder in that deserted
country, on those destroyed paths
that have no compassion
for travelers.
>> Consuelo Hernández: And
now I'm going to read one poem
that I think is more
actual than ever.
It's La inmigrante
and it's devoted to --
dedicated to all the
immigrant women.
Mujer que caminas noche y día con
tu llave inmemorial das nacimiento a
la palabra veraz atraviesas el
río y nadie te reconoce, te mojas,
sudas, pierdes tus zapatos.
Otra jornada abrumada de cansancio,
no puedes verbalizar tus
injurias pero eres sabia aunque te
encuentren infraganti.
Te interrogan.
¿Quién eres?
¿De dónde vienes?
¿Qué buscas en esta tierra que ya
tiene dueños y fronteras y murallas
y hermanos que saben
de la muerte lenta?
Al espacio de tu linaje vuelves como
sombra que releo en tu luminosa faz
el fuego no termina escapas,
caes, te levantas, te sacudes,
hablas en tu lengua de tortilla
muerdes tus palabras de café y no
te dejas derrotar por la nostalgia.
Tu canto se ahoga, se alejan las
salidas eres inmigrante tu identidad
se ha reducido para siempre.
No entiendes de visas ni de planetas
fragmentados aprendes a decir
"good morning" pero
a nadie le interesa
"how you are" ni que estés habitada
por un hijo sepultado en el desierto
por el sueño de un empleo de
un refugio para dormir en paz.
Yo también soy la ruptura de la
costura aquí adentro no se disipa
la niebla, y me sucede que
miro en tu espejo y me veo.
>> Maureen Contreni:
Immigrant woman.
Woman that walks night and day
with your memor -- in memorial key.
You give rise to the true word.
You cross the river and
no one acknowledges you.
You get wet, you sweat,
you lose your shoes.
Another day's journey
burdened with exhaustion.
You cannot verbalize your
injuries, but you are wise even
if they catch you red-handed.
They interrogate you.
Who are you?
Where are you from?
What do you want from this land that
already has owners, and borders,
and walls, and brothers
who know about slow death.
To the place of your lineage
you return like a shadow
that I reread in your
luminous visage.
The fire does not end.
You escape, you fall, you get up.
You shake yourself off.
You speak in your tortilla
tongue coffee words.
Do not let nostalgia defeat you.
Your song drowns.
The exits get farther away.
You are in immigrant.
Your identity has been
reduced forever.
You neither understand about
visas nor fragmented planets.
You learn to say good morning, but
no one is interested in how you are,
or that you are inhabited by a
son buried in the desert by hope
of getting a job, of a
refuge to sleep in peace.
I too am the rupture and the scene.
Here inside the fog does not
dissipate and so it happens
that I look at your reflection
in the mirror and I see myself.
>> Consuelo Hernández:
Volver a la niñez.
Volver a la niñez, se dice
fácil, al delantal de flores,
al mate rile-rile-ró, al tuntún
del diablo con el tridente al
hombro, al ángel con
el bastón dorado,
a las madrugadas de
cuatro de la mañana,
a visitar los templos
con devoción forzada.
Volver a los juegos de pelota,
a escalar los montes de los
Andes con frío avaricioso,
cruzar el puente sobre el
ruido infernal de la quebrada,
con un miedo que muerde las agallas.
En verdad poco hay de
memorable en todo esto,
tal vez mi soledad entre la hierba,
el diálogo inconcluso
con los pájaros,
y mi permanente envidia de sus alas.
Mas para qué toda esta
perorata de nostalgias,
si al final sé que soy igual que
el Amazonas o el Potomac que siempre
van y nunca pueden volver
a su punto de partida.
>> Maureen Contreni:
Back to childhood.
Back to childhood, it's easily
said, to the flowery apron,
to mate rile-rile-ró, to the
beat of the devil with a pitchfork
on his shoulder, to the
angel with the golden staff,
to the early starts
at 4 in the morning,
visiting temples with
forced devotion.
Back to ball games, to
climbing the Andes mountains
in the grasping cold, to crossing
the bridge over the inferno noise
of the gorge, with fear
gnawing at our insides.
Honestly, little of
this is memorable.
Perhaps just my loneliness in the
grass, my inconclusive dialogue
with the birds, and my
permanent envy of their wings.
But why all this nostalgic
sing-songing
if in the end I know I'm just
like the Amazon o r the Potomac
that always flow and never
return to their starting point.
>> Consuelo Hernández:
And I'm going to conclude
with this poem for my parents.
I am also an orphan already
and this is already sad poem,
but I want to read it here.
Te fuiste.
Te fuiste a mitad de
la cosecha de verano,
entraste a casa del silencio.
Todas las palabras recogiste.
No dejaste con la mirada húmeda y
el corazón luchando contra pelo.
Que triste aquella noche contigo
hasta alba sin oírte pronunciar
una palabra.
Te miraba y desde la eternidad de mi
sonreías con tus ojos cerrados de
ternura y tu andar
detenido por siempre.
Repetí tu nombre hasta
el cansancio.
Los momentos que pasamos conversando
y te vivirte como estatua en mi
misma me habitadas.
Hoy en el reino del insomnios estás
aquí suavizando mi dolor con tu
pecho generoso y tus
últimas palabras:
Hija mía que Dios me la bendiga.
>> Maureen Contreni: You went away.
You went away in the middle
of the summer harvest.
You entered the house of silence.
You gathered up all your words.
With a damp look, you left us
with our hearts struggling
against the tide.
Such an unhappy night
with you until dawn,
not hearing you utter one word.
I looked at you and you smiled
back at me from eternity.
With your closed eyes
and tenderness,
your movement stopped forever.
I repeated your name to exhaustion,
the times we spent talking.
I saw you rise up like
a statue inside me.
You inhabited me.
Today in the kingdom of insomnia
you are here softening my pain,
with your generous chest,
and your last words:
God bless you, my daughter.
[ Applause ]
>> Catalina Gómez:
That was just beautiful.
Thank you both.
And just a small reminder that
we're selling Consuelo's book here
in the back.
Thank you for coming.
Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.